libretti what is going on welcome to the
second akivi tutorial basics video in
this video we're just gonna kind of
build on top of the last video so in the
last video we had this really basic
application and what was happening was
they're just popping up with a simple
hello world label but as we could see it
was already resizable into you know
basically many different sizes so it
would work on all kinds of different
devices and screens and obviously we can
see that's already at least you can you
know kind of close the window and that
was about it I don't really have any
other I don't know uses for this other
than we just wanted to show some text
now let's say we actually want to build
a simple application and let's say the
first screen is some sort of a login
screen so how do we do that well first
of all what's all that's happening so
far is we've got this ki V app class
here that we're inheriting from with a
simple key v class of our own we inherit
from there and then we define the build
and the only thing what's happening in
our build is we're just returning a
label so that's all our app does is
returns a label now obviously that's a
little impractical that's not really
what we want to do so instead let's say
for now our app only has login screen so
what we want to eventually return login
screen okay so now we need to define
login screen there's no login screens
that I know of with TV luckily for us
TVs has a few more things than on top of
Pi game as far as you know kind of built
in things that you can use but I don't
believe login screen is one of them
anyways we'll come on down whoops
wrong button come on down here now and
now let's go ahead and define our login
screen now this is going to be a little
thicker than the last tutorial so stick
with me but I'll do my best to explain
everything that I'm doing so first of
all we can leave this label import but
now what we're going to actually do is
we're going to bring in the layout so
first let me just type it from K v UI x
dot grid layout we want to in
poor capital G grid capital L layout uh
we'll leave that and the grid layout
there's I think like five or six
different types of layouts and we'll
kind of cover that those in a little bit
but basically the layouts are used their
layout it's kind of like a from tkinter
for example you had two major types of
layouts you had a grid layout and you
almost had like look at what the other
one was it was more like a relative kind
of layout and so grid layout you can
imagine it's you know based on grids and
there's all kinds of different layouts
with keavy this is just one of them so
anyway we're going to use the grid
layout and then finally because it's a
login screen we need some way to
actually import her input rather text so
next thing we're going to do is from a
TV UI X dot text input we're going to
import capital T text capital I input
and that really should be it I think we
might need to import the base key V but
I'm sure that's necessary here anyway
we'll see if we run into it so first
what we're going to say is we're going
to call our class and obviously we need
to name it login screen so I'm going to
copy launch main class login screen and
is there anything we want to inherit
from well we want to inherit from grid
layout so this is your kind of back end
stuff it's your back end layout so it's
not just like a simple class we want to
actually we're going to inherit from
this entire grid layout so I'm going to
copy that paste that in again if you're
not comfortable with the idea of
inheritance check out the crash course
to object-oriented programming tutorial
I have so a class login screen grid
layout and as you're probably familiar
with if you understand object-oriented
programming is the first class we're
going to write or the first uh sorry the
first method we're going to write is
going to be our init method so define
underscore underscore init underscore
underscore whoops just do and then we're
just going to self and then we're gonna
have orgs which is just kind of like an
arbitrary number
added keyword arguments and the first
thing we're going to do is super and
we're going to super the login screen
cell and then dot underscore underscore
init underscore underscore and then
asterisk asterisk kwargs okay so
basically what this is going to do is so
we don't actually have to reference our
base class okay so this will allow us to
kind of use multi inheritance rather
than just you know grid layout so define
in it Oh
basically our init class does that then
we're going to say self dots
uh calls for columns equals we're going
to say two and then we're going to say
self dot add underscore widget and the
widget we're going to add is this label
widget right up here and so the label
widget and within that we're going to
say the text equals lost my mouth there
we go
username okay so that's our first widget
now you might be able to guess now what
might come next is but we need the the
next widget which is basically a text
input widget so now we will say self dot
username and that's obviously going to
be referencing whatever they type in
here so how do we reference that well
we're going to say self dot using equals
text input referencing this so text
input and then we're going to say
multi-line equals false and this is
because it's not a paragraph here is a
single username so we don't need many
lines here so multi-line equals false
and then we can say self dot add
underscore with JIT and now we want to
add the widget of self dot username and
that's basically it for adding a
username so I think we should be able to
get away with running this real quick
and see where we stand we'll see sure
enough there we go we have a username
and if we click in here we can already
are typing in our text appears so again
all of those things kind of happen for
us and it's because it's not multi-line
you could hit enter and we are actually
outside now of this text box when we hit
enter so cool so anyways we can close
this close this and now let's go ahead
let's like add a couple more things so
we have two columns but basically we can
continue adding new widgets so we could
in theory let's just try this let's copy
this and our enter paste and now let's
say this is password self dot password
equals that copy password paste it here
and now let us save and run that and so
now you have your username is a sent X
and your password
oops int X and your password is awesome
oh no our password is actually showing
the text so that's kind of a problem huh
how do we write some code to solve that
well TVs done that for you
so when you come down here you got
multi-line equals false we can actually
just add another parameter here
multi-line equals false password equals
true it's just a parameter in a text
input and password equals true what it's
going to do is just make your password
asterisks so now we can save and run
that and username again can be syntax
and then I keep on to hit tab as I'm
expecting it to work anyway password is
awesome but you don't see its asterisks
now so pretty cool so now um actually
I'm a little curious see if we can copy
this if come down here paste oh they are
aspis okay cool anyway uh moving on so
you got username password I mean this
the list could go on right so we could
say we get another one we could say self
dot add the widgets a two factor auth
right so your two-factor authentication
we don't need to leave the password bar
there and then we can say TF a so we
can't do
2fa but anyway TFA save and run that and
now you've got you know username
password two-factor off you can enter
all that we don't really have a login
button but well I guess we can talk
about that and a little bit so that
those just like you know some basics to
creating some simple input some simple
interactivity and just like before we've
actually coded quite or we've got an
application that requires quite a bit of
code but since kV does most of the work
for us we don't really need to write
that much I mean most of this code is
actually fairly redundant right this all
this is pretty much just copy and paste
we change the label a little bit but for
the most part I mean this isn't really
that complex yet we've made it pretty
you know I mean the window itself that
we created is pretty simplistic but the
amount of code required in the true
back-end right if we look at all the
code involved in text input and grid
layout and label and key V dot app which
we've already seen and I think I showed
label in the previous video it's a lot
of code so it saves you a lot of time
and it's definitely nice for rapid
development so anyway that's it for this
video if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and it's till the next
video